plus on va continuer la conversation
après avoir écouté jean pierre cassel
jean pierre cassel qui va nous
interpréter un extrait de son spectacle
alors qu'à celles on le connais parce
qu'il a tourné avec renoir bunuel l'osé
chabrol ou qu'il a joué shakespeare
donc il est évident et acteur il est
comédien mais il est aussi chanteur et
là il est dans un tour de chant qui
s'appelle je ne peux pas vivre sans
amour où il reprend un certain nombre de
grands textes de gainsbourg traîner
nougaro ferré brel salvador ou encore
bourvil et ce soir accompagné par gilles
clément à la guitare luigi trussardi à
la contrebasse et eric des revues à la
batterie il interprète c'était bien
c'était tout juste après la guerre dans
un petit bar inc avait souffert sur une
piste de nuit c'est vous le dis en avait
deux à découvrir
parmi les gravats il dansait pour ce
petit ban qui s'appelait circulait
il est simple
10 et plus
non je ne me souviens plus du nom du bar
perdu
me souviens ce sont ces amoureux qui ne
regarde rien
élever ton dans son sillon
un geste gimont alors quelle importance
du ban de pedro
non je ne me souviens plus du nom du bol
perdu
ce dont je me souviens c'est qu'ils
étaient heureux mes yeux au fond des
yeux
c'était bien
et c'était bien
oh
il met beylongue le même verbe toujours
sans se quitter des yeux
il faisait là même brillait d'être
toujours toujours heureux
parmi les gravats il souriait donc ce
petit baveux qui s'appelait
j'appelais
vous vous appelez
il s'appelait
non je ne me souviens plus qui nous dit
balles perdues
ce dont je me souviens ce sont ces
amoureux
regardez rien autour d'eux devait être
conscient
majesty mur alors qu'elle important
d'ubs a perdu
non je ne me souviens plus du nom du bar
perdu
ce dont je me souviens c'est que des
miettes et heureux
mieux au fond les yeux
c'était bien
on
et puis quand un corps des nonistes
s'est arrêtée ils sont partis le soir
tombé dessus de la piste sur les gravats
ont mis sur ma vie il est devenu tout
rice le p'tit bal qui s'appelait
qui s'appelait 10 appelé qui s'appelait
non plus
on se souvient
ces symboles qui ne regardent peut rien
tours le
il y avait tant de lumière
avec eux dans la rue
apple a fait
le nom du ballon perdu
je me souviens plus du nom du bar perdu
ce dont je me souviens c'est qu'on était
heureux
messieurs en fout des yeux
j'ai fait bien
c'est derrière
m
j'étais bien haut
jean pierre cassel
c'est au théâtre de dix heures